all right everybody welcome back - here
we are back live with our Raspberry Pi
we have our two jumper wires a resistor
and an LED light now the only thing that
we're kind of missing from this circuit
that you'll probably see a lot of is a
capacitor so what a resistor is doing
just just for a quick quick basic I
promise I want to talk too long on it
but you should know if you don't a
resistors purpose is to resist the
current so what you can think of a
circuit as an current as like a current
of water so when you add a resistor to a
circuit what it's going to do is it's
literally going to resist that current
and it will change the current of the
entire circuit right so again if you
think of it as water if one area of the
river
for example flows at like two feet a
second and the other part of the river
is flowing at 18 feet a second when it
gets to the part of two feet a second
it's going to overflow right and so you
can't have that happen in a circuit if
you've built it right anyways um so what
a resistor will do is slows down the
entire circuit at specific points and in
this circuit here we're just having one
resistor we're not going to split the
circuit so once you do that then you
start getting into a little bit deeper
math this should be pretty simple again
your LED you could do the math but if
you're not comfortable with doing the
math just start with a really really
high high resistance and go from there
so let's start plugging everything in so
first thing we want to do is I guess
we'll plug in the LED first and so as
you can see on the LED it's actually
it's got a different lengths of plugs
here and the one that's longer is always
positive than is it yeah depending on
how you cut it but officially the
convention is the longer is the positive
shorter is negative if you've ever seen
like a diagram it's going to have like a
long line and a short line the short
line is the negative terminal of the
battery and the long line is
terminal battery so anyway we'll plug in
our led and just plug it in with a
negative facing towards you so what I'm
going to go ahead and do is just put it
into my breadboard now sometimes as you
poke something into a red breadboard
just it doesn't want to slip in really
easily don't force it it should kind of
glide it in if you're if you find
yourself really pushing very hard just
take a second
and try again so anyway I'm trying to
figure what the heck to do with this so
just want to make sure you all see where
I'm plugging everything ynx you just
have to make a circuit the next thing
you want to do oh and if you don't know
anything about breadboard
you should probably a research a little
bit on the breadboard the idea of the
breadboard is just so that you can build
the circuit without soldering and it's
not just for noobs and amateurs it's a
good way to just to quickly test and/or
build and then test a circuit before you
actually you know commit and begin
soldering so the next thing we want to
do is we're going to want to resist this
I'm sorry I plug this into funky supply
I just want to make a cute little cube
or square anyway you'll have to
besides ground I suppose doesn't matter
as much but you want everything
connected so right now we've got you
know the positive is over here this is
the negative we want to connect our
resistor and it needs to be in the same
kind of row basically as our LED light
I'll show this to you real closely in a
second now ideally you would trim the
resistor so it's like you know flush but
for this vs. will be bit sticking up but
as you can see you know there here's the
negative here and then there's the
resistor plugged in there's a resistor
goes into the side row here now what we
want to do is connect let's connect our
ground so we'll put the male end into
our breadboard here now this could
really go anywhere on these on this side
so you can put it here or here or here
but we're going to put it here is to
make everything nice and
Luud and this we will have eyes our
ground so the ground pin from if you
know from the top absolute right is the
third pin down just be totally careful
here as you're connecting things so one
two three and they're all just so close
together just don't want to make a
mistake so that is our ground so now
connect that and I lost my other jumper
here it is now what we want to do is
connect the positive and we're we set
GPIO pin 18 if you don't know which one
18 is it's going to be another three
pins down from where you just plugged in
the ground so it's the sixth pin down so
count one two three four five six so a
gap of two pins just have to make
everything nice and clear because we
don't want anybody screwing up so again
push this one down that's plugged in now
the last thing we want to do is plug
that into our pin or our board here
okay and you want to plug it in you know
flush with the positive in the same row
as the positive part of your led is so
now we've done that everything's hooked
up and but the program is not running so
now we want to go back over to our
terminal and begin running this program
so the next thing we want to do is open
up the terminal and right now we aren't
in that home slash PI so what we're
gonna want to do is CD into home slash
PI and just make sure we got where we
want to go let's LS and sure enough
there is our file that we want to run so
to run this program what we have to type
in is sudo python and so this just says
super user do using python we want to
run our program which we call GPIO
example dot py now when we hit enter the
goal is this it's going to ask us the
password and obviously now that we're
running the program you can see here the
LED light has become illuminated so this
means our lock is engaged but let's say
let's say we type in what is pot or yeah
what is pi what if the person says 3.14
it's enter wrong password
nothing happens what if the person
enters the correct password then you sue
awesome enter sure enough there goes the
light and in a few seconds it will turn
back on sure enough our lock is back
engaged so you do all kinds of stuff now
if you wanted to you know just kind of
have a little good time you could say if
we pop back over here and we kind of
edit the program a little bit and so
let's just have ourselves a bit of a
good time and let's do
Oh true and so sleep for let's do point
o2 and then we'll ask here and then
we'll do any time sleep another point up
we'll save our new program we'll come
back over to the terminal here and to
exit this little program you could just
hit the X here let's not do that
let's do hold control press C and that
will break the script now as you can see
our the LED light itself has remained on
so what I should have done is entered
the right password then interrupted it
and turned it off because if you leave
the pin on the pin will stay on but
otherwise let's go ahead and rerun this
program so you just hit the up arrow and
it puts the same thing in there and now
it's going to do is it's just going to
flash our light really really really
fast
I'm not even sure hopefully my camera's
picking it up but if you do this in
person you'll see that the light is
indeed flashing really fast we could do
point five seconds instead we could save
it we can come back over to a terminal
ctrl C stops it up arrow hit enter one
more time and now it flashes every half
a second okay so you can start playing
around with the program and the LED
light and stuff and this is just you
know a really quick example of having
your program interact with the physical
world which is really cool because now
we can do we do all kinds of stuff right
you can use your input to the computer
to interact with a camera motors like
wheels you can make like a rover that
interacts with your keyboard input as we
go on all kinds of stuff I mean is the
possibilities are really infinite so
it's really exciting I hope you guys
enjoyed the video as usual thank you for
watching thank you for your support your
subscriptions hope you guys a have fun
with your GPIO and I'm just enthralled
with this thing and until next time